hey guys today i'm actually going to do
a video on how you can customize your
can prompt
uh so first of all
you have to be able to find command
prompt so uh just type cmd in the start
search bar and hit enter which will open
the first program here and you can see
i've already changed my text to red
so how you change uh how you customize
command prompt is very simple you right
click on the c the command prompt icon
and hit defaults
and you'll be able to change uh the
options the font the layout of it um
including the size
the position and the colors that are
involved so first of all i'm going to go
over font
uh you see a little preview window over
here you can choose the size of your
command prompt window
i left mine at 7 by 12 just because i'm
used to that size
and then you can choose
the actual font that's involved there's
only one font here
i'm going to use to console
and i'll use size
14 make it easier to see
then in terms of layout
you can actually change pixel by pixel
how wide it is if i want to make mine
more widescreen
um
i can change the actual length of it or
the width of it and shorten the height
maybe to 250
or 275 which is good
and then change the colors the colors is
usually the most fun to play around with
you can choose the screen text
which is the actual red that i've chosen
here and you can change it to brighter
red
um i'll leave it at that and then you
can change the screen background which
is this black you see you can make it
bsod color you can make it
a different
pink gold i'm going to leave it at black
it's just very sharp contrast and then
also the pop-up windows i left at purple
and white so that's pretty cool
that's basically how you can oh yes you
can choose um you can have it in quick
edit mode and you can also choose your
cursor size as you mouse over it so
that's how you customize a command
prompt console window i hope you found
this tutorial helpful and by the way
after you've made all your changes
you're going to exit out
and then type in cmd again and open it
up
it'll have applied all your changes
notice a little different size and it's
also brighter
so that is how you
customize command prompt to your liking
and it'll open the same way every time
you might have noticed i had a web kit
up here every time i open webkit it'll
it'll all look instead of being just
plain black and white you'll have a
little something to look at it'll be red
and black so just if you're bored
so um that's how you customize command
prompt i hope you found this tutorial
helpful if you have any other video
ideas for me
or tutorial requests and just subscribe
send me a personal message and i'll get
right to it so thanks for watching peace